[Musique]
bienvenue dans cette émission spéciale
consacrée à la cybercriminalité aussi à
la cybersécurité c'est-à-dire comment
sont protégés parce que la
cybercriminalité probablement la
criminalité la plus dangereuse des
années qui viennent elle est déjà là et
on va en parler avec Nadjet sumar
bonjour vous êtes formatrice à l'école
my DJ tal school exactement
de cybercriminalité autre et de
débrouiller au fond de te protéger de la
cybercriminalité
à côté de vous avez vos sacs bonjour
vous êtes directeur des opérations c'est
s'il reste qui est une entreprise de
cybersécurité c'est ça exactement pas
dire mieux
une des ça va être intéressant parce
qu'on va aussi parler du marché de la
cybersé qui est un marché en pleine
expansion et non seulement en pleine
expansion économique aussi fournisseur
d'emploi exactement
de startup qui est une une entreprise de
formation au métier de du cyber un
métier comme du digital et vous êtes la
côte riz avec avec Maëlys bulk de
stratégie et marketing
c'est ça exactement sortie en 2022 et
donc à jour exactement
de de mettre de la cyberculinité et vous
allez nous parler notamment de la loi
qui est en discussion aujourd'hui la loi
dans la loi sécurité il y a un grand Pan
qui concerne la cyber effectivement
on va on va peut-être commencer par
panorama si vous êtes d'accord de ce
qu'est la cybercriminalité aujourd'hui
et parce que ce des chiffres sont
absolument effrayants et vous allez on
va les commenter ensemble si vous voulez
bien
[Musique]
les chiffres de la cybercriminalité sont
assez impressionnants
si on dit que c'est une des plus grandes
menaces sur l'économie mondiale on dit
que la cybercriminalité rapporte déjà
plus que le trafic de drogue c'est quand
même assez impressionnant que 54% c'est
une majorité d'entreprises françaises
auraient déjà
été l'objet d'une cyberattaque
les chiffres mais enfin bon c'est il y a
beaucoup d'entreprises en effet qui qui
sont qui sont victimes de cyberattaques
et on verra tout à l'heure et toutes nos
portes pas plaintes d'ailleurs
ils ne sont pas assurés on dit 18
millions de Français auraient déjà été
victime d'une d'une cyberataque
que le coût moyen d'une attaque c'est
50.000 euros
du phénomène non alors oui
moi j'ai une phrase que j'aime beaucoup
qui n'est pas de moi qui est de
Guillaume poopard qui est le directeur
général de l'Agence nationale de la
sécurité du système d'information qui
dit qu'il existe que deux typologies de
société aujourd'hui en France celles qui
se sont fait hacker et celles qui le
savent pas encore et je pense que ça ça
résume assez bien aujourd'hui les
attaques que l'on ressent sur les
entreprises sont exponentielles alors on
entend beaucoup parler de façon
assez assez symbolique des centres
hospitaliers ou ce genre de choses qui
sont voilà qui sont effectivement des
des attaques
qui sont sur entre guillemets qui sont
connus enfin et qui sont connus et qui
ont beaucoup d'impact mais on parle
assez peu en fait de de
TPE PME qui sont des cibles d'attaque et
qui est particulier d'ailleurs et les
particuliers au même titre complètement
tout à fait et qui sont attaqués très
enfin très régulièrement et qui ont des
des
qui peuvent avoir des conséquences
effectivement qui sont très très graves
voire des employés qui ne se relèvent
pas en fait de ce genre de ce genre
d'attaque
alors j'ai oublié de préciser que vous
êtes formatrice à magical School et que
nous avons dans ce studio
beaucoup d'étudiants de première année
de cette école et à la fin de l'émission
dedans trail
Chloé Amandine viendront nous dire voilà
ce qu'elles ont retenu ou ce qu'elles
ont pensé de cette émission c'est vrai
que c'est un phénomène très important
quoi on n'a pas l'impression comme ça on
avait l'impression la supercriminalité
c'est quelque chose pour demain or c'est
déjà là c'est déjà aujourd'hui c'est
nous quoi je pense que la
cybercriminalité criminalité ça existe
depuis très longtemps mais l'effet de
transformation numérique qui a été
causée par la crise sanitaire notamment
qui est un peu accéléré les choses a mis
un petit peu en visibilité toutes les
problématiques qu'on pouvait avoir
autour de ça donc depuis quelques années
le gouvernement s'y intéresse beaucoup
parce qu'on a été un des pays le plus
attaqués en Europe et donc comme le
disait
ça effectivement on a quelques exemples
mais qui ne sont qu'une partie visible
de l'iceberg aujourd'hui la
cybercriminalité elle touche tout le
monde elle touche les particuliers elle
touche des stars aussi comme Kim
Kardashian qui avait été victime de
cyberatta qu'on a fait chanter qui a dû
payer d'invention etc donc c'est c'est
un phénomène qui qui est très
intéressant ce que vous dites parce que
c'est vrai que sous le nom de
cybercriminalité au fond il y a beaucoup
extrêmement
et il y a beaucoup peut-être de aussi de
à cœur différent
est-ce qu'il y a des grosses
organisations de la mafia une mafia du
cyber ça existe ça
oui oui en fait ce sont des entreprises
c'est-à-dire qu'il faut savoir que vous
avez des groupes de hackers qui
passent des annonces pour embaucher
d'autres groupes de hackers et avec des
gens qui sont payés tous les mois
parce que ils construisent voilà il y a
une nouvelle typologie de mon
somewherware puisque c'est quelque chose
que tout le monde n'entend parler
actuellement on va définir
les choses
de cœur et de cybercriminalité quoi
exactement donc qui propose un service
c'est à dire qu'aujourd'hui elle propose
des services elle propose des des des
des des des virus
[Musique]
Ahmed pour pour être mise à disposition
d'autres hackers et aujourd'hui
n'importe qui pourrait potentiellement
devenir hacker parce qu'effectivement
faut être assez intelligent pour
concevoir cette certaines choses par
contre on n'a pas besoin d'intelligence
juste savoir surfer sur Internet pour
aller récupérer l'information et devenir
soi-même à coeur avec l'aide de ces de
ces de ces pirates sachant que pour
répondre à ce que vous disiez tout à
l'heure la cybercriminalité c'est la
pâte du gain c'est à dire que faut pas
on est dans du crime c'est des crimes
organisés et on est pour récupérer on
est là pour récupérer l'argent
oui et d'après le site de gouvernemental
je crois
47 formes de cybercriminalité alors
voilà si on va dans les détails
évidemment c'est important mais les plus
gros c'est le piratage des comptes en
ligne et les attaques par ce qu'on
appelle les ronces fongiciels
en fait vous avez le principe est de
chiffrer vos données donc les rendre
illisibles pour faire simple
par vos propres services donc en fait
chaque entreprise
comme tu le disais tout à l'heure à son
propre système d'information aujourd'hui
quel que soit la taille de l'entreprise
on est sur un système informatique
et aujourd'hui les gens ne pensent pas
en fait puisque ça n'arrive qu'aux
autres que quelqu'un peut accéder soit
par du phishing soit
parce qu'on appelle des failles 0D AC en
fait au système d'information de
l'entreprise ou du particulier et donc
chiffrer les données qui se trouvent à
l'intérieur et lorsque vous chiffrez la
trésorerie d'une entreprise lorsque vous
chiffrez les données vous n'y avez plus
accès et donc là se pose la question de
savoir si vous n'avez pas été résilient
et si vous ne vous êtes pas posé la
question au préalable de savoir comment
vous allez vous en sortir et après sans
rentrer dans les détails le deuxième
phénomène et l'extorsion de fond on va
dire sur l'extraction des données c'est
à dire que ils se sont aperçus que pour
lutter contre le rançon logiciel on
pouvait être résilient en effectuant des
sauvegardes je vais pas rentrer dans le
détail mais voilà et donc comme le but
du jeu c'est quand même de faire de
l'argent et qu'on sait qu'aujourd'hui il
reste plusieurs jours voire plusieurs
semaines à l'intérieur des systèmes
d'information lorsqu'ils y ont eu accès
ils vont extraire en fait tout un tas
d'informations tout un tas de données
et donc on va arriver sur une deuxième
forme de chantage par la suite si on ne
paye pas puisque on peut repartir sur un
nouveau système ça effectivement de dire
que on va diffuser les données donc là
on rentre sur les problématiques de de
données personnelles à caractère
personnel avec la CNIL notamment avec le
principe du rgpd ou encore tout
simplement les données stratégiques et
qui font la force et la vigueur de nos
entreprises françaises on l'a vu
pour faire simple quand même il y a
toujours demande de rançon au départ
après un
piratage alors sur un cadre en son
logiciel oui puisque le but du jeu c'est
de faire de l'argent
et la publication des données comme on
l'a vu quand à l'hôpital qui est voilà
qui s'est fait hacker il y a quelques
mois donc la menace c'était de rendre
public les informations
qu'ils avaient ça c'est c'est pourquoi
c'est parce que l'invention n'a pas été
payée ou c'est notre forme de
je pense que dans ce milieu là il y a
aussi avant cette notion de d'argent il
y a aussi un vrai goût du challenge
c'est à dire que craquer un système
concours entre entre la cybercriminalité
les cybersécurités
là de hacking et donc il y a aussi le
challenge d'avoir craqué en système de
sécurité français les hôpitaux enfin les
hôpitaux de Paris en l'occurrence c'est
quand même rattaché à l'état français
donc quand un hacker craque ces systèmes
là avant même la notion d'argent je
pense qu'il y a je pense qu'il y a ça
aussi qui en fait on peut considérer
peut-être qu'il deux typologies
d'attaque il y a celles qui touche le
secteur privé donc les entreprises et là
ça peut mettre en danger certaines
entreprises parce que certaines
entreprises peuvent être en défaillance
suite à une cyberattaque et puis il y a
une typologie plutôt d'attaque ciblées
sur le secteur public et là c'est la
souveraineté qui est réellement en jeu
on entend souvent que aujourd'hui
la cybersécurité est un enjeu de
souveraineté et on le voit quand les
collectivités quand la fonction publique
hospitalière est attaquée c'est certes
le centre hospitalier et des données
publiques qui sont qui sont cryptées
mais c'est aussi l'état français qui a
attaqué et c'est là dans un cadre on le
sait aujourd'hui de contexte de guerre
et de conflits en Ukraine souvent ça
peut aussi venir et ben de Russie de
pays qui qui sont
en conflit en conflit avec avec la
France donc il y a vraiment un enjeu
aussi de souveraineté quand c'est les
collectivités publiques les services
d'état qui sont attaqués sans compter
les gros événements et 4 milliards alors
un chiffre peut-être qui est assez
important lors des Jeux Olympiques de
Tokyo Jean-Michel fourgon c'est beaucoup
le répéter parce que il se prépare il a
conscience que pour les Jeux Olympiques
de Paris en 2024 il y aura un enjeu de
cybersécurité lors des Jeux Olympiques
de Tokyo et bien il y a eu 4 milliards
de cyberattaque durant l'événement et là
pour 2024 ah bah 2024 je pense que c'est
un enjeu qui est en pris en compte par
les services de l'État et par les
collectivités puisque je vous le disais
Jean-Michel fourousse président de 50
ans en Yvelines et ben on parle sur
lequel il y a il y aura des territoires
sur lequel il y aura des épreuves
d'ailleurs il y a beaucoup de beaucoup
d'entreprises
ici dans les dans les Yvelines sont
spécialisés dans la cybersécurité vous
êtes vous êtes assez nombreux vous êtes
parti aussi du blédard pour Samsung
le secteur de cette cybersécurité alors
on est on est trop peu
il y a beaucoup d'entreprises
d'informatique il y a très peu de
sociétés spécialisées en termes de
cybersécurité puisque c'est des métiers
différents et dans l'informatique il y a
énormément de métiers on est très très
peu et je crois que sur les derniers
chiffres que j'ai entendus voilà je veux
pas je crois qu'on rien que sur
l'Île-de-France on manque de 35000
personnes je crois les emplois c'est
juste un petit peu énorme donc oui on
fait partie d'une d'une communauté
puisque de toute façon la défense se
fera essentiellement par le le
maillage territorial de des entreprises
telles que la nôtre mais effectivement
on est on reste on reste des entités
très très peu nombreuses par rapport à
ce qu'on a à faire mais c'est vrai que
sur ce territoire aussi effectivement
beaucoup de beaucoup d'entreprises il y
a des écoles comme my digital School il
y a l'école
spécialisé dans la hypersécurité alors
il y a un enjeu de formation mais c'est
pour ça que l'État français c'est aussi
investi pour lancer le cyber l'école
cyber à la défense avec plusieurs
entités de formation qui sont regroupés
à la défense mais il y a aussi un enjeu
oui de compétences parce que vous le
savez Patrice j'en compte pas mal
d'entreprises sur le territoire de 50
ans en Yvelines et il y a beaucoup
d'entreprises dans la cybersécurité qui
sont en manque de et qui sont en
recrutement en permanence parce que par
exemple pour citer on a Airbus cyber
sécurité qui est sur le territoire
Élancourt il y a Thalès aussi ces deux
entreprises ont ce qu'on appelle des
stocks c'est des centres d'opérations de
contre-attaques c'est là où sont
regroupés des des personnes qui sont qui
ont l'objectif de contrer les attaques
qui sont présents pour sur le alors
c'est des clients et bien sûr ils
passent des contrats et des entreprises
contractent avec ces entre ce Airbus ou
Thalès pour avoir des personnes qui
protègent leur système et après vous
avez d'autres entreprises à 50 ans 10
minutes je pense à prophétie prophétie
qui a un centre de formation donc là
c'est leur job cette proposer des
formations en cybersécurité et je pense
aussi à oxybox François fejas qui lui
propose un système
où on peut stocker son système
d'information pour éviter lors d'une
cyberattaque d'avoir une rupture
d'activité c'est à dire que vu que le
système d'information est stocké à
l'extérieur si le système est attaqué et
ben il y a une continuité du service
voilà quelques exemples d'entreprises
sur le territoire de
Saint-Quentin-en-Yvelines
Virginie
les entreprises avec laquelle vous
travaillez ce qu'elles sont tout était
attaqués ou pas
est-ce qu'on disait tout à l'heure c'est
que il y en a qui ne le disent pas et
puis il y en a qui aussi sous-estime
l'impact d'une petite attaque au départ
ça peut être via le site internet via
c'est parfois des petites choses mais ce
qui est important c'est je pense c'est
de communiquer enfin si on parle tout à
l'heure de comment répondre quand on est
attaqué mais c'est vrai que c'est vrai
qu'il y a parfois
c'est en train de changer mais peut-être
un peu de une sorte de honte avoir été
attaqué
[Musique]
la partie les obligations légales il y a
et puis il y a aussi le voilà exactement
la notoriété vis-à-vis des vis-à-vis des
clients vis-à-vis des collaborateurs
aussi dictionnaire que les actionnaires
enfin ça touche tout le milieu toutes
les tous l'écosystème effectivement
beaucoup d'entreprises préfèrent
aujourd'hui
de se défendre contre cette
cybercriminalité mais il faut en effet
que c'était cette esprit change et vous
nous parlerez de la loi qui est
discutait aujourd'hui et qui fait en
sorte que les entreprises portent
plainte dès qu'elles sont des questions
attaquées on va je vais juste
ce que j'ai vu parce que on a vu
l'hôpital qui avait été attaqué et j'ai
vu aussi qu'il y avait des hackers qui
ça c'est le corps c'est terrifiant qui
peuvent changer des dossiers médicaux
des gens c'est-à-dire faire croire à un
médecin que quelqu'un va tout à fait
bien
changer les résultats c'est c'est
terrible quand même à partir du moment
où vous accède
la vraie problématique qui est
d'ailleurs qu'on les entreprises ou les
hôpitaux ou autre c'est de s'apercevoir
qu'on a accéder à leur réseau le temps
en fait entre le moment où le hacker va
accéder au réseau et où l'entreprise va
s'en apercevoir c'est là la la grande
problématique et par rapport à ce que
vous disiez sur les entreprises qui
travaillent sur le secteur je crois que
le gouvernement est en train de mettre
en place quelque chose que je trouve
très intéressant c'est de démocratiser
le sujet parce que certes des
entreprises qui sont spécialisées dans
la cybersécurité mais la cybersécurité
c'est l'affaire de tous finalement parce
qu'à partir du moment où on accède au
réseau de l'entreprise
quel que soit le salarié de l'entreprise
en fait c'est parler salariés de
l'entreprise car il y a eu les
cyberattaques donc ce sont des éléments
de vigilance à mettre en place dans la
vie tous les jours qui font qu'on va
sécuriser qu'on va protéger le le
système ma digital school c'est une
école qui qui forme des étudiants de bac
tout de suite après le bac jusqu'au bac
+ 5 et ce sont des étudiants qui sont
spécialisés dans le digital mais de
manière globale ce sont pas des
informaticiens et on est en train
justement les former à les
cybersécurités pour les sensibiliser
dans leur vie de tous les jours
du digital à protéger le système à
sécuriser le réseau etc donc c'est
vraiment les petites actions tous les
jours qui font que on peut faire évoluer
des choses
c'est comme façon covid il y a des
gestes barrières pour éviter d'être
contaminé par le virus et en fait j'ai
déjà entendu ça dans plusieurs
conférences sur la cybersécurité mais il
y a aussi des gestes barrières à avoir
pour éviter d'avoir et bien de subir une
cyber-attaque des petits gestes par
exemple quand on voit on reçoit un mail
suspect c'est une palourrir parce que il
peut y avoir je vous interroge justement
parce qu'on aborde ce problème c'est
comment comment se protéger contre la
cybercriminalité
[Musique]
Nicolas alors vous rejoignez tout à fait
Nadège sous marque parce que vous avez
beaucoup travaillé justement sur comment
le grand public les gens qui sont pas
formés peuvent se défendre contre la
cybercriminalité et vous citiez si un
mail un peu suspect plutôt que d'être
curieux et d'essayer de savoir ce que
c'est souvent c'est parce que pas mal
aussi c'est de regarder quel est le quel
est l'expéditeur non
ça donne ça donne des informations
généralement oui enfin aujourd'hui dans
les statistiques l'un des premiers
vecteurs en fait d'infection
effectivement c'est ce qu'on appelle le
phishing on reçoit un mail
malicieux et on va cliquer et ce genre
de choses donc effectivement il faut pas
il faut le supprimer le alors le mieux
c'est déjà qu'ils n'arrive pas sur la
boîte mail pour ça il y a des outils
pour éviter les anti spams les les voilà
mais ça donne des contraintes puisque la
cybersécurité sera fera forcément des
contraintes et on va jauger entre les
contraintes qu'on va appliquer et
effectivement la vie d'entreprise pour
répondre effectivement aller dans la la
dans tout ce qui a été dit auparavant
qui est la juste titre la vérité le
premier maillon de la chaîne ça va
rester l'humain et c'est aussi le
maillon le plus faible de la chaîne
c'est-à-dire qu'aujourd'hui on peut
dépenser des millions dans sa
cybersécurité ou 10 euros dans un cyber
sécurité ça passera toujours par
l'humain donc effectivement et on sait
qu'aujourd'hui sur je crois sur les
dernières qu'on est à 9 personnes sur 10
qui sont non sensibilisés dans les dans
les entreprises donc 90% des
collaborateurs oui c'est déjà le premier
pas cette sensibiliser c'est ce que vous
disiez avec vos élèves par exemple cette
sensibiliser les gens qui vont
travailler dans les entreprises et vous
vous dites au fond il y a des gestes
relativement simple
qu'on peut utiliser qui permet de se
prémunir contre ces attaques exactement
alors il y a l'Agence nationale de
sécurité des informations
depuis un an voire deux depuis justement
qu'on a été sujet à de très grosses
cyberattaques et puis il y a eu je pense
tout ce travail de transformation
numérique qui a été fait dans
l'accélération à cause de la crise
sanitaire par des personnes qui
n'étaient pas du tout sensibilisés à la
cybersécurité donc on a construit des
systèmes sans en tenir compte et
aujourd'hui on est en train de revenir
en arrière pour sensibiliser le grand
public donc moi j'ai avec moi justement
les 12 conseils que Hansi donne
un public exactement on peut aller sur
le site ils font des webinaires ils font
des formations d'ailleurs moi j'ai une
formation avec eux ils sont je fais des
interventions en entreprise qui
sensibilisent les salariés je trouve ça
très bien pour revenir régulièrement
justement pour ces gestes là et alors
eux ce qui préconisent alors c'est déjà
choisir son mot de passe enfin c'est à
dire qu'il faut avoir un mot de passe
personnalisé qui n'est pas un mot de
passe avec son prénom sa date de
naissance etc donc un mot de passe avec
des chiffres et des lettres qui n'ont
rien à voir mettre à jour régulièrement
les logiciels puisque les logiciels
antivirus en fait il recense tous les
virus qui sont connus et si on a
Monsieur informatique dans les
entreprises qui vient régulièrement nous
voir c'est pas pour nous embêter c'est
parce que justement la mise à jour des
logiciels va répertorier tous les virus
connus ensuite bien connaître les
utilisateurs et c'est prestataires
c'est-à-dire que on va éviter les
communications avec des gens qu'on ne
connaît pas ou l'accès à certains
fichiers
effectuer des sauvegardes régulières
pour éviter justement d'avoir un
effacement de toute sa base de données
sécuriser l'accès aux wifi de
l'entreprise parce que les peuvent aussi
se faire par le wifi
être prudent avec son ordinateur ou sa
tablette
professionnelle donc ne pas partir en
vacances par exemple avec son ordinateur
professionnel parce que bah oui si vous
amusez à télécharger des chansons des
films etc bah c'est aussi souvent comme
ça voilà
donc ça c'est un des conseils qui
donnent pour les salariés d'ordre
général protéger ses données lors de ses
déplacements être prudent lors de
l'utilisation de sa messagerie
télécharger ces programmes sur des sites
officiels des éditeurs donc on a souvent
l'habitude d'aller télécharger sur 01
téléchargement etc ça c'est à éviter
parce que on vous donne des logiciels
qui sont dits gratuits mais derrière
c'est là-dedans qu'on va mettre des
virus justement pour accéder au réseau
être vigilant lors d'un paiement sur
internet séparer les usages personnels
et les usages professionnels et ça je
moi pour moi c'est un des premiers
conseils exactement et prendre soin des
informations personnelles
professionnelles de son identité
numérique d'accord oui donc c'est pas
mal et ça tout ça toutes ces conseils on
peut les retrouver sur le site de
lentilles exactement tu as fait un très
très gros travail je trouve justement de
démystifier le sujet parce que les gens
ont souvent l'impression que la
cybersécurité c'est un sujet très
technique
on peut déjà se protéger chacun chacun
en étant avec un peu de bon sens quoi
enfin exactement tout simplement mais
Xavier vos sacs je pense que parfois ça
va plus dans les clients qui sont vos
clients font en fait tout type de risque
tout type de clients on a des grosses
entreprises on a de la PME PMI alors la
majoritairement de la PME PMI compat
effectivement de Monsieur cyber à
l'intérieur de leur de leur
infrastructure et et qui vont partir
d'un principe c'est-à-dire qu'en un
moment donné
l'un des avantages du rgpd ça a été de
faire prendre conscience au chef
d'entreprise
le règlement général sur la protection
des données à caractère personnel pardon
qui est en vigueur depuis 2018 en France
enfin et comme nom dans tout l'Union
européenne
et donc il y avait une obligation légale
en fait d'identifier les données à
caractère personnel au-delà de ça ça a
permis de au chef d'entreprise de se
poser les questions sur où étaient les
valeurs de l'entreprise
et donc notre métier c'est de l'analyse
de risque en fait on ne gère que du
risque on part d'un principe puisque la
meilleure défense c'est de comprendre
que ça va nous arriver et donc de
d'essayer de mettre des éléments en
place qui peuvent être la sauvegarde qui
peuvent être de la différents typologies
de redondance puisque vous avez
effectivement la la perte des données ou
l'accès à ces données là mais vous avez
également pour une entreprise la
disponibilité des données
aujourd'hui effectivement comme tout le
monde le disait on est en permanence sur
son système informatique si je n'ai pu
accès à la donnée comment je fais les
gros je fais voilà donc
exactement donc faut réfléchir en fait à
tout ça et mettre des actions en
conséquence aujourd'hui il faut savoir
qu'il y a on disait si on parle des
éléments de mot de passe si on arrive
dans il vous le premier si j'arrive et
que je vous dis allez aujourd'hui on va
changer tous les mots de passe de tous
les logiciels que vous utilisez
et vous allez me faire quoi vous allez
mettre un mot de passe relativement
simple et vous allez me changer soit la
première lettre soit le dernier chiffre
si vous faites si vous le combinez comme
ça et donc ça veut dire qu'à un moment
donné si vous faites confiance à des
entreprises externes de toute façon qui
se sont fait elles pirater puisque c'est
pas forcément de vos fêtes mais qui
elles sont fait pirater qui récupère
votre identifiant qui est souvent votre
adresse mail et le mot de passe qui est
associé et ben je peux mener des
attaques ciblées par la suite ou repérer
donc il pour arriver avec des solutions
et il y a des aujourd'hui des
gestionnaires de mots de passe il y a
beaucoup d'éléments qui sont open source
c'est à dire
gratuits
difficiles à trouver quoi
et qui sont difficiles à retenir surtout
la problématique c'est ça et c'est pour
ça qu'il faut utiliser des gestionnaires
de mot de passe puisque si j'arrive et
je vous dis aujourd'hui vous allez en
utiliser 30 différents dans la journée
soit j'ai le droit aux petits cahier
soit j'ai le droit aux fichier excel qui
n'est absolument pas sécurisé qui va
induire en fait indirectement une faille
une faille de sécurité donc il faut
donner effectivement les outils au
personnel des entreprises en leur
donnant des gestionnaires de mot de
passe alors facilitant la tâche puisque
comme je disais tout à l'heure la
sécurité c'est une contrainte donc il
faut mettre des antivirus il faut mettre
des firewall aujourd'hui on voit trop
d'entreprises qui n'ont toujours pas
d'antivirus c'est fou mais il y en a et
notamment certaines également qui sont
dans le secteur de la santé
des entreprises qui sont un peu en
retard quoi oui parce que les
entreprises vont dire mais moi je suis
pas un centre hospitalier je suis pas et
puis j'ai pas d'obligation légale à ce
niveau-là et puis ceci et puis cela puis
j'ai pas de données et puis j'ai pas de
données importantes et en général les
gens qui subissent une super attaque qui
sont relèvent parce que toutes
heureusement beaucoup sont relèvent mais
beaucoup ne sont relèvent pas non plus
une fois qu'ils sont relèvent font une
analyse de risque et vont regarder
effectivement tout ce qu'il y a et de se
dire bah si je mets des murs blindés
mais que je mets un une porte en
laissant la clé sur la serrure
complètement du bon c'est avant tout du
bon sens Virginie dans les formations de
start-up par exemple vous avez beaucoup
de formateurs qui forment notamment
réseaux sociaux enfin pour les salariés
des entreprises pour les entreprises
elles-mêmes
est-ce que le la notion de cyberattaque
fait partie de ces formations ce qui
forment justement les les les
par exemple à faire attention à voilà
pas trop de vulgué de choses on va se
protéger je pense que ça commence déjà
enfin c'est de la communication de crise
donc après bad buzz cyberattack c'est un
sujet de savoir communiquer et pas
camoufler aujourd'hui
rien de pire qu'un client qui apprend
par quelqu'un d'autre que par
l'entreprise en elle-même que
l'entreprise a été piratée que ces
données sont visibles donc aujourd'hui
les entreprises elles se doivent de
communiquer après de quelle manière ça
s'anticipe c'est à dire qu'il faut pas y
aller comme ça sous mode réaction
entreprise je viens d'apprendre que
j'étais l'objet d'une cyberattaque
qu'est-ce que je fais il faut il faut le
dire il faut pas le dire il faut
première chose avant la cyberattaque on
peut déjà envisager des scénarios et
préparer ça c'est-à-dire préparer sa
communication online c'est être présent
avoir ses propres médias enfin en tout
cas ses comptes sur les réseaux
communiquer régulièrement créer du lien
rassurer ça c'est la base ensuite il
faut bien distinguer le type d'action
qui a et peut y avoir des anomalies des
incidents mineurs majeurs et après il y
a les vrais crises de
c'est quatre sujets qui se traitent
différemment et puis après il faut aussi
définir un porte-parole parce qu'on l'a
vu dans des communications de crise le
porte-parole quand il est pas bon quand
il intervient au pas au bon moment pas
de la bonne manière avec les bons mots
ça peut être très compliqué donc
exactement
ça se prépare et puis il faut aussi
identifier les toutes les parties
prenantes on l'a vu dans certains cas
récents les actionnaires les salariés la
presse les clients les prestataires les
autorités publiques en fait il faut
oublier personne il faut avoir aussi un
message et un plan d'action par cible
manager est en train aussi de grimper
pas seulement pour de la communication
commerciale mais aussi pour ça ça
s'intègre parce que faut rassurer le
client il faut être présent faut créer
ce lien faut en permanence parce que si
les entreprises et
hacker enfin
évidemment les clients de cette
entreprise se disent ben voilà mes
données sont
il y a une panique qui peut qui peut
être de ça non
c'est d'ailleurs pour ça que les
entreprises on disait tout à l'heure ne
communique pas beaucoup parce qu'ils n'y
sont pas préparés 50% de peine de porte
plainte et alors question pardon non
quelque part aussi parce qu'on l'a vu
même sur des pannes sans parler de
d'attaque mais sur des pannes comme
Instagram récemment ils se sont excusés
publiquement tout de suite il y a eu un
message on peut retrouver l'information
et parfois même du coup ça renforce
encore plus le lien qu'on a avec la
marque parce que on sait maintenant
qu'on est tous vulnérables enfin on peut
tout savoir une cyberattaque donc
effectivement il y a un bon boulot
ça peut être aussi l'occasion encore
plus de montrer non seulement qu'on est
transparent et que on a envie d'avoir
une relation de confiance mais en plus
on prend des mesures et des mesures
concrètes à la suite et ça peut encore
plus rassurer des clients et je pense en
convaincre certains travaillent avec
l'entreprise donc alors j'ai vu vos sac
entend souvent dit voilà les hackers
si on est en son il faut payer ou pas
c'est une très bonne question ma
position est non
la position générale non j'ai
l'impression de les spécialistes et les
consignes de l'ancienne alors c'est les
consignes de déjà pour commencer et je
pense qu'elles sont très bonnes
à ça adoré enfin plusieurs raisons la
première c'est même si vous payez vous
n'êtes pas sûr de récupérer vos données
ah oui
exactement vous n'avez aucune garantie
si vous voulez vas-y 62% des entreprises
attaquées la rançon mais 47% seulement
récupèrent leurs données qu'ils ont
souvent critiques
et je vais rajouter un chiffre à
celui-ci qui est que 43% des entreprises
qui ont payé qui ont récupéré leurs
données se font réattaquer dans les
quatre mois qui suivent voilà
donc les chiffres
exactement ils ont payé donc ils vont
repayer on en revient toujours au
principe de l'argent c'est toujours
pareil
donc la si vous êtes bien préparé
entre guillemets c'est pas grave si vous
si vous faites chiffrer vos données mais
que vous êtes en capacité de redémarrer
c'est pas grave si les données qui sont
volées elles sont chiffrées ce n'est pas
elles sont pas exploitables ce n'est pas
grave non plus donc tout ça faut en fait
faut de l'anticiper faut se préparer
auprès au préalable et de se dire de
toute façon ça va m'arriver c'est comme
pour la communication ça va m'arriver
qu'est-ce que
on sait pas c'est pas quand ça va
arriver
voilà exactement et vous
et aussi que au fond on peut c'est comme
un vaccin quoi la cybersécurité on peut
se vacciner contre les attaques un peu
c'est ça alors oui on n'est pas immunisé
mais par contre on peut faire en sorte
et si tout le monde la communauté non
c'est enfin l'ensemble des entreprises
prend conscience de ça ça va rendre les
choses plus difficiles si vous avez
parce qu'on a toujours moyen d'y arriver
aujourd'hui le wifi a été hacké enfin
voilà beaucoup de choses ont été acquis
c'est une question de temps et on y
arrive toujours la seule problématique
c'est que
si on est à l'universitaire on peut
passer deux ans trois ans de recherche
pour hacker un système si vous êtes une
entreprise commerciale ou un coeur qui
est là pour faire de l'argent on va pas
dépenser deux une année deux années
trois années avec des systèmes
importants pour essayer de craquer
certaines informations
c'est exactement c'est exactement le
même principe donc
cette relativement on a l'impression que
c'est un monde sympa mais au fond c'est
un peu le même le même monde que le
monde réel enfin le but du jeu pour les
cyberattaques parce que je parle pas des
risques généraux dans l'entreprise du
système d'information la cyberattaque
c'est bien c'est bien une entreprise
criminelle et donc le dont l'objectif
est de faire de l'argent absolument donc
facilement et rapidement c'est pour ça
qu'aujourd'hui les
je quand je disais que tout le monde
était et susceptible d'être attaqué
c'est qu'aujourd'hui il faut c'est pas
des humains derrière ce sont des robots
qu'on va qui sont lancés sur Internet
qui scannent le web en règle générale et
qui va trouver en fait des failles et à
partir du moment où les failles sont
trouvées là effectivement on a des
hackers qui vont venir regarder ce qu'on
peut récupérer ce genre de choses donc
tout le monde est susceptible au début
on sait pas qu'on s'appelle X ou Y ils
savent pas qu'ils vont attaquer telle
typologie de structure ou telle autre
et donc c'est pour ça qu'il faut que
tout le monde prenne conscience
qu'effectivement ça peut arriver à
chacun pardon
si vous payez la rançon vous pouvez
participer aussi au financement du crime
mondialisé puisque ça participe aussi au
financement à la fois du trafic du
trafic de drogue et ça et du terrorisme
c'est pour ça aussi que la DGSI est
engagée sur ce sujet là parce que vous
avez raison différentes
sur ce sujet vous voulez ajouter quelque
chose de il faut payer la rançon ou pas
sur cette protection
ce sujet là je rejoins tout le monde je
pense qu'il faut pas payer parce que
c'est en actilégal et que c'est quelque
part c'est encouragé le la continuité de
tout ça après je pense que dans la
réalité c'est aussi une estimation de
coups c'est-à-dire que c'est se dire je
paye pas la rançon qu'est-ce que ça va
me coûter pour remettre en place le
système pour mettre un système de
défense qui va bien et puis si j'arrive
pas à récupérer ma data qu'est-ce que je
fais des entreprises qui quand elles
perdent leurs data c'est le burn out et
donc là c'est le chiffre d'affaires qui
tombe donc il peut voilà je pense que
dans la réalité c'est pour ça qu'on a 40
plus de 40% des entreprises qui payent
c'est qu'il y a un enjeu financier
toute la raison pour ne pas payer et
puis parfois voilà on est dans la
panique on est dans l'émotion on est on
est dans l'urgence dans le calcul aussi
le mauvais choix Nicolas il y a donc
cette loi sécurité qui est en discussion
aujourd'hui l'assemblée et dans cette
voie sécurité il y a volé sur la
cybersécurité c'est ça la loi
d'orientation et de programmation du
ministère de l'Intérieur qui a été en
première lecture au Sénat et là qui
arrive à l'Assemblée nationale et donc
plusieurs dispositions qui sont
préconisées dans cette loi d'abord créer
un appel d'urgence aujourd'hui on a le
17 pour contacter la police là ça serait
le 17 cyber c'est à dire que si vous
subissez une attaque vous pouvez appeler
le 17 cyber et ça permettra de signaler
justement qu'on a été victime d'une
cyber attaque ensuite il y a une
augmentation des moyens 1500 cyber
patrouilleurs déployés 1500 personnes
supplémentaires il y aurait une école de
formation de la cyber du ministère de
l'Intérieur
et des outre-mer et sensibiliser aussi
100% des entreprises au risque de
cybercriminalité il y a d'autres choses
aussi notamment cette disposition parce
qu'aujourd'hui faut savoir qu'il y a
seulement 3% des entreprises qui sont
assurées contre ce risque et donc et ben
le gouvernement dans cette loi veut
favoriser justement le fait que les
entreprises s'assurent par rapport à ce
risque en rentrant obligatoire tout en
rendant aussi obligatoire le dépôt de
plainte au minimum 48 maximum 48 heures
après la cyberattaque pour être
indemnisé par rapport à ce risque donc
le gouvernement veut augmenter le nombre
d'entreprises assurées mais vrai aussi
augmenter le nombre de plaintes qui sont
déposées par rapport à une cyberattaque
et permettre justement de lancer des
enquêtes ensuite parce que le but c'est
ça c'est de d'essayer d'arrêter ceux qui
sont derrière ces cyber-attaquent
d'accord Virginie je reviens je reviens
à la communication des entreprises
est-ce qu'on
peut dire qu'il faudrait privilégier
transparence ou moi je pense que c'est
important mais c'est la base de toute
communication nous on accompagne de
nombreuses entreprises et aujourd'hui à
construire cette confiance mais dans la
durée pas au moment où on a un problème
il faut la construire
et après on comprend qu'effectivement
tout il faut dire les choses d'une
certaine manière il faut aussi avoir des
mesures en face et on dit il y a un
problème et on est dessus et qu'est-ce
qu'on fait en face évidemment mais voilà
c'est des choses qui se préparent faut
pas être dans la précipité
on communique plus pareil sur les
réseaux sociaux on crée on crée du lien
beaucoup plus fort on essayait de
construire des relations beaucoup plus
basées sur l'humain et donc avec
vraiment de l'émotion et je pense que il
y a un vrai sujet à construire du lien
pour pour finalement ne pas être touché
ne pas perdre tous ses clients ou la
confiance de ses clients en cas de
problème quoi donc vous accompagnez vous
les entreprises de leur communication
sur le
la prime vous êtes plutôt spéciste vous
de la technique de
spécialisé dans la communication chacun
chacun justement
à son boulot nous on va effectivement
soit intervenir dans la phase audit donc
essayez de déterminer avant ce qui ne va
pas
ou alors dans la phase remédiation
effectivement forentzig parce que le il
est très important de de dans une
cyberattaque en fait ce qui ce qui
compte c'est le temps le temps joue
contre nous et donc faut gagner du temps
absolument
ce que disait virgi c'est-à-dire que
c'est important c'est la prévention
c'est très important c'est peut-être le
premier pas quoi dans la protection on
va passer peut-être au troisième thème
de l'émission c'est à dire le marché le
marché de la cybersécurité qui
visiblement un marché d'avenir ou de
Didier on manque d'entreprise
[Musique]
évidemment beaucoup de métiers dans la
dans la cybersécurité de métiers
différents
les chiffres sont un peu il y a déjà 750
000 emplois dans la cybersé énormément
alors j'ai pas les chiffres exacts
il faut il faut juste savoir quand en
l'espace de quelques années les
effectifs au sein des entreprises
dédiées à la cybersécurité on
on fait une croissance exponentielle
et vous avez vu
un accroissement à une demande du métier
de la cybersécurité oui complètement
tout à fait oui 5 ans c'était
encore un peu rare non c'était le début
quoi presque
enfin pour rejoindre en fait c'était
plus un petit peu plus mise en valeur et
effectivement un peu moins un peu moins
mis sur les réseaux et ce genre de
choses et puis les entreprises étaient
une gestion du risque qui était un petit
peu différente par contre la l'activité
cyber enfin cybercriminalité a toujours
existé depuis que les systèmes
d'information existe
tout à l'heure
dans la conceptualisation même du
process c'est-à-dire qu'on va mettre mis
en place des barrières de sécurité c'est
comme quand vous construisez votre
maison si vous faites une maison sans
porte sans fenêtre vous avez des chances
qu'on rentre à l'intérieur donc si vous
mettez un portail sécurisé avec une
porte sécurisée plus un verrou sur votre
porte des fenêtres avec des volets etc
vous avez moins de chance que les gens
puissent y accéder la cybersécurité
c'est exactement ça on va mettre des
barrières de sécurité qui vont empêcher
les cyberattaques donc dans la
conceptualisation même et donc c'est des
métiers
architectes informatiques etc vous avez
des grosses sociétés qui travaillent
là-dedans
plein de métiers différents justement
vous vous êtes vous enseigner dans une
école qui est Mike digital school alors
vous disiez vous faites pas précisément
de la formation la cybersécurité mais ça
fait partie des des secteurs qui sont
des secteurs d'avenir enfin des secteurs
porteurs d'emploi exactement
c'est c'est secteur porteurs d'avenir et
puis surtout je trouve que c'est un
sujet qui est très important aujourd'hui
parce que notre gouvernement est très
clairement attaqué et mise à mal par
rapport aussi berattaque donc je pense
qu'il y a une volonté gouvernementale de
démocratiser le sujet et de sensibiliser
le grand public autour de ça et c'est ce
que je fais chez ma digital School et
puis de manière plus générale dans dans
ma vie de tous les jours pour deux
objectifs
sensibiliser un maximum de personnes et
puis féminiser un petit peu le milieu
aussi d'ailleurs que la féminisation du
métier pouvait aussi changer
notre rapport peut-être à la
cybercriminalité ou réponse à y apporter
je pense que comme dans tous les métiers
un peu Haïti un peu tech c'est un milieu
qui reste très masculin voilà il est en
train de se baigner ça veut peut-être
changer un peu un peu les choses c'est
en train de changer il y a quand même de
grosses entreprises comme Orange
Capgemini qui ont ouvert leurs écoles
alors en Bretagne il y a une sorte de
Silicon Valley qui est en train de se
[Musique]
c'est la même chose c'est exactement la
même chose
il y a beaucoup de décolles sur ce
territoire de formation
[Musique]
mais il y a aussi des territoires et
c'est ça qui est intéressant c'est que
les collectivités locales se saisissent
aussi de cet enjeu je pense notamment la
région qui il y a un appel à
manifestation d'intérêt qui est en cours
sur le lancement d'une cybercaverne en
région Île-de-France l'idée serait de
rassembler plusieurs justement
défenseurs informatiques qui serait dans
une caserne en fait comme une caserne de
pompiers et qui répondrait du coup aux
urgences de cyberattaque notamment pour
les collectivités locales parce qu'on
l'a vu ces derniers temps et encore la
semaine dernière le Département de
Seine-Maritime qui a été victime d'une
cybératrice et les collectivités sont
font face et là c'est mon deuxième point
c'est aussi le département des Yvelines
qui a engagé sur ce sujet avec scène et
vie numérique l'agence qui est
spécialisée sur les sujets numériques
dans le département et ben depuis le 14
juin il me semble ils ont lancé une
offre donc à la fois pour une offre de
formation pour les agents publics donc
par exemple des fonctionnaires qui
pourraient être formés justement
reste barrière et ça c'est sa numérique
qui le propose et bien pour aussi
installer des systèmes développés des
systèmes de cyberdéfense dans les
collectivités locales mérit
intercommunalité voilà parce que tout le
monde est
peut-être victime de cyberattack
Virginie j'ajoute que il y a quand même
pas mal de budget aussi effectivement
pour former et puis pour transformer les
entreprises accompagner dans toute la
partie digitale mais c'est aussi
sécuritaire c'est tout donc et c'est
vrai que je trouve que pour le coup là
la région il y a pas mal de choses
peuvent être actionnées pour pour
transformer enfin voilà pour accompagner
la transformation digitale des
entreprises et notamment en matière de
formation nous on le voit parce que on a
beaucoup d'entreprises du territoire qui
ont bénéficié du problème
[Musique]
à tout moment on n'est pas forcément
forcé d'être de spécialiste des des
réseaux sociaux de des internet surtout
que nous on accompagne beaucoup
surprise avec des salariés qui
finalement ont mon âge qu'on pas
toujours eu des formations initiales
avec du numérique dedans donc des gens
qui finalement parfois découvrent le
digital et donc il faut accompagner et
puis remettre à jour et accompagner
vraiment sur un suivi l'idée c'est de se
dire qu'en fait tout le monde même les
salariés d'aujourd'hui qui n'ont pas eu
cette ce socle initiale peuvent
aujourd'hui complètement monter en
compétences dans le domaine donc c'est
notre rôle chez Star Trek alors je vais
vous remercier Nicolas et Virginie parce
que je vais accueillir deux étudiants
dans un instant
on va justement je vais passer puisque
ça ça résume ce que vous disiez vous
avez fait une
un extrait de Nathalie vous avez fait de
d'Emmanuel dotaro qui le vice-président
de Thalès et qui explique pourquoi selon
qui explique pourquoi sur d'autres
entreprises est intéressée par le
domaine de la cybersécurité et puis je
veux recevoir Chloé et Amandine de deux
étudiantes de magnétis cool merci
beaucoup Virginie merci beaucoup Nicolas
dandry
Emmanuel de tarot je travaille chez
Thalès et mes activités concernent deux
grands sujets la cybersécurité et de les
infrastructures numériques dont les dans
les réseaux en particulier
[Musique]
Thalès vend des systèmes et des systèmes
critiques en général du système où les
vies humaines peuvent être en jeu et
donc le niveau de sécurité c'est système
et de façon indispensable forcément
élevé on ne peut pas développer la
technologie pour faire de la vie unique
dans un avion avec la sûreté des
commandes de vol sans se poser la
question de la cybersécurité on peut pas
se poser la question depuis l'otage du
système industriel critique dans le
domaine du nucléaire par exemple sans se
poser la question de la cybersécurité et
il y a une partie pure de cybersécurité
ou la cybersécurité se vend sous forme
de produits ou de services et l'encours
étant de éteindre nos socles des
endroits où on opère la cybersécurité
tous les gens peuvent externaliser ou
profiter des compétences d'un acteur qui
est qui suit au jour le jour les menaces
et les solutions de cyber sécurité et
donc une partie de ces de ces opérations
la plus grosse partie historique est à
Élancourt
voilà c'est vrai que oui c'est des
entreprises Thalès évidemment
comprend pourquoi alors on reçoit Chloé
et Amandine bon bonjour vous êtes vous
êtes élève en première année digital
school vous avez assisté à l'émission
j'avais dire une question comme ça on
parlait de ça avec Xavier vos sac mais
si vous étiez formé à la cybersécurité
vous serez plutôt du côté de la des gens
qui défendent ou du côté des hackers
logiquement une formation dans le
digital c'est qu'on est intéressé par
des choses qui touchent à ça et donc on
est quand même sensibilisés au fait
qu'il faut se protéger protéger les
données donc plus du côté de la défense
dans votre formation c'est important de
vous sensibiliser à cette à cette donnée
vous vous sentez voilà c'est quelque
chose qui vous tient à coeur
qui vous intéresse totalement sur tous
les tous les sites tous les codages
qu'on fait tout ça etc on a réellement
besoin de d'une sécurité sur tout ce
qu'on fait sur tout ce qu'on entreprend
parce que sinon on perd toutes nos
données absolument puis c'est une
question de génération aussi c'est vrai
que nous on est né dans ça donc on est
sensibilisé depuis petit en fait tous
ces risques puis on entend forcément
plus parler que des personnes plus âgées
qui sont pas sur les réseaux sociaux
donc oui c'est important de sensibiliser
surtout dans mon métier qu'on fera plus
tard vous avez choisi de faire votre
scolarité à my digital school
bon donc c'est parce que c'est un
domaine qui vous intéressez évidemment
c'est quel est le métier que vous
aimeriez exercer
moi j'aime beaucoup je suis intéressé
par le
développement web et aussi par tout ce
qui est
community manager ça déjà beaucoup la
communication digitale donc il y a un
mélange un peu tous avec en première
année on voit de tous les domaines donc
tous les secteurs donc on a intéressé un
peu partout enfin en tout cas pour ma
part
la direction artistique et le design
donc c'est un peu un peu différent un
peu différent de du développement tout
ça mais comme comme a dit Chloé on l'a
la première année on le fait vraiment
tous les troncs communs donc peut-être
que peut-être qu'à la fin de l'année je
vais changer de voix à voir c'est vrai
il y a beaucoup de beaucoup de métiers
qui
auquel vous former évidemment
sur tous les métiers du digital que on
soit dans de la conception de la
création ou de la stratégie digitale
pure du community management sont des
diplômes qui sont reconnus par l'État
qui sont assez valorisés dans les
entreprises donc c'est une école qui a
une très bonne réputation et je trouve
et moi je salue vraiment l'effort qu'ils
ont fait de d'intégrer justement toutes
ces formations cyber sécurité pour
sensibiliser tous les corps de métiers
du digital autour de ce sujet là c'est
très en cohérence avec ce que fait le
gouvernement avec ce que ce que subit le
pays et je trouve que c'est un vrai
effort qui a été fait je salue l'école
pour ça est-ce que vous avez une
question
en commentaire non je suis moi par
exemple je suis intéressée aussi par
cybersécurité et en tant que femme je
trouve ça aussi important est-ce que
vous vous en parliez tout à l'heure de
la féminisation de ce métier du domaine
là
exactement
très intéressant et puis tout ce que
vous avez évoqué sur la prévention aussi
c'est la sensibilisation je trouve ça
très important et j'espère que d'ici peu
il y en aura davantage donc voilà de
toute façon c'est plus en plus répandu
en ce moment il y a de plus en plus de
sites où on peut pas mettre les mots de
passe qu'on veut il faut mettre des
symboles particuliers pour être sûr de
toute façon vous l'avez évoqué tout à
l'heure faites de mettre des mots de
passe de plus en plus compliqués pour
être sûr
pendant pendant des années donc je pense
que s'il reste de belles années ça
devrait être en fait merci merci
beaucoup merci beaucoup
merci beaucoup d'être sûrement merci
beaucoup et Xavier Beaussac et je
rappelle le livre de Virginie fever
stratégie et e-marketing voilà c'était
co-écrit avec pask et merci à tous alors
j'espère que on pourra reparler parce
que c'est il y a évidemment c'est une
course-poursuite un peu entre les
hackers et les spécialistes de la
sécurité comme toujours exactement
merci merci à tous et à très vite pour
une nouvelle émission de PAF
[Musique]